[SPEAKER_00]: On the topic, Unlocking Digital Innovation, e-government and its relevance for African natural resource management.
[SPEAKER_00]: Next slide, please.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, our presentation is here to provide some time to think about the diagram of the network of the topic in order to have objectives in the technology level, start, completion, and policy options.
[SPEAKER_00]: Next, please.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sustainable management of natural resources is central to the achievement of sustainable development goals.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yet, natural resource depletion remains an existential challenge in Africa, with many countries still very dependent on natural resources for revenue and export permits.
[SPEAKER_00]: As a matter of fact, between 2010 and 2013, Africa lost about 3.97.2 million hectares of forest land each year, and over 45% of the world's degraded land is affected.
[SPEAKER_00]: Moreover, more than 900 million
[SPEAKER_00]: do not have access to clean floors and technologies for cooking.
[SPEAKER_00]: And this has drive massive deforestation and demand for firewood and charcoal.
[SPEAKER_00]: This often results to over exploitation of natural resources, illegal mining,
[SPEAKER_00]: climate vulnerability, corruption, and waste-seeking behavior.
[SPEAKER_00]: Next slide please.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, to limit depletion and impact dependence on natural resources, most studies have suggested some policy options.
[SPEAKER_00]: For instance,
[SPEAKER_00]: The study suggested we should move to knowledge-intensive export and economic complexity and try to diversify products and add value to our raw materials.
[SPEAKER_00]: Other studies recommend renewable energy taxing and transition to clean cooking works, while others recommend openness to trade, climate financing, and carbon credit.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, the persistent rates of depletion that we currently observe in Africa suggest that the current measures are not nearly sufficient to halt the trajectory of resource exhaustion in Africa.
[SPEAKER_00]: Next slide, please.
[SPEAKER_00]: In this regard, e-government emerges as a promising yet unexplored dimension
[SPEAKER_00]: in addressing the challenges of natural resource management in Africa.
[SPEAKER_00]: Studies have actually shown that e-government adoption reduces corruption by improving transparency and accountability in public administration, while also enhancing the efficiency of public service delivery and strengthening decision-making quality by increasing bureaucratic inefficiencies
[SPEAKER_00]: promoting citizen engagement.
[SPEAKER_00]: And finally, e-government platforms can equally facilitate citizen participation and monitoring of public resource use, enhancing institutional accountability.
[SPEAKER_00]: Next.
[SPEAKER_00]: Based on this background, we built the following research framework to express the linkages between e-government and natural resources.
[SPEAKER_00]: And for the two objectives, the first one is to assess whether e-government maturity or adoption reduces natural resource depletion in Africa, and we also aim to track the mechanisms through which these linkages occur.
[SPEAKER_00]: Next.
[SPEAKER_00]: In order to achieve this objective, we use data from the United Nations e-government survey, which is a database that actually tracks and records how deep governments actually digitize the services they provide to their citizens.
[SPEAKER_00]: We also use the World Bank, World Development Educators,
[SPEAKER_00]: and the worldwide governance indicators.
[SPEAKER_00]: Natural resource depletion was used here as a proxy for natural resource management, and it measures how a country utilizes and exports un-depleted natural resources.
[SPEAKER_00]: That is, depletion is said to occur when resources consumed are consumed at a faster rate than they can be renewed.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, for the variable of interest we have already explained there.
[SPEAKER_00]: We also controlled for some microeconomic variables like population growth, openness to trade, foreign direct investment, and economic growth.
[SPEAKER_00]: Next.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, for the empirical methodology we specified three models.
[SPEAKER_00]: Actually, we have more than that.
[SPEAKER_00]: We have the fixed effects model to capture the direct effect, which is complemented with the dynamic panel model of Arulano and Dover and Yonder and Don.
[SPEAKER_00]: We also use the panel regression to also look at the conditional index at the various
[SPEAKER_00]: levels of natural resource depletion.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then finally, we have a negation model from Balan and Kay to try to track the transition mechanisms.
[SPEAKER_00]: Next.
[SPEAKER_00]: Results, we can have seen here results from the fixed effect model.
[SPEAKER_00]: and you can see that the government majority reduces natural source depletion and the coefficient is actually significant when you look at the stand alone effects and even when we are trying to control for the macroeconomic variables and the Osman Tesk Sotel was the
[SPEAKER_00]: fix effect model were actually appropriate.
[SPEAKER_00]: Next, please.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, these results were also confirmed by the system GNN Estimate, which you can see on the table.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, the meditation analysis also shows that
[SPEAKER_00]: An important size effect of the effects of the government on natural resource suppression transits through control of corruption and government effectiveness.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can clearly see that a greater percentage is gained through controlled corruption and a less but still important percentage is also obtained from the government effectiveness.
[SPEAKER_00]: Next, please.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, this result actually shows that the adoption of digital technologies and the offer of online services by governments can actually help African countries to gain efficiency in the management of their natural resources.
[SPEAKER_00]: And we also found that online service delivery
[SPEAKER_00]: online service quality exerts a stronger impact than the telecommunication infrastructure highlighted that infrastructure alone is necessary but it is insufficient because we don't only have to get these services i mean like get the infrastructure set and we also ensure that these are effectively implemented
[SPEAKER_00]: Interestingly, we also found through the Pantai regression that countries experiencing higher depletion rates would benefit the most from government depletion.
[SPEAKER_00]: Next please.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, based on the findings, we recommend that first investment should be directed towards expanding and modernizing
[SPEAKER_00]: digital infrastructure to strengthen digital innovation in resource management.
[SPEAKER_00]: And like we said, it shouldn't just be infrastructure expansion alone, but we should really make sure that these measures are actually implemented.
[SPEAKER_00]: For instance, when I was called up to come and present for this conference,
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm in South Africa for now.
[SPEAKER_00]: I hold a Cameroonian passport.
[SPEAKER_00]: And when I applied to get a visa, there was actually an e-government platform to, I mean an e-visa platform to apply for a visa for Ivory Coast.
[SPEAKER_00]: I applied there, and up to now, I still don't have a response.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, so when I saw that, I was very happy that I was able to just apply online and have a visa.
[SPEAKER_00]: I still don't have any response.
[SPEAKER_00]: So if we were just looking at how the Ivorian government, for example, is putting up digital services, we would already conclude that that's nice, but I don't know, maybe it's not just for me, but the implementation, we still need to really work on that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, the second recommendation is that the government should also mandate the publication of natural resource contracts, licenses, and revenue flows on accessible open data in government borders, integrating global anti-corruption and governance standards such as the Extracted Industries and Transparency Initiative
[SPEAKER_00]: We also recommend capacity building programs also essential to ensuring that digital tools are not only adopted but are effectively utilized in policy formulation, monitoring, and enforcement as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: And also, finally, we recommend promoting regional cooperation and exchange of digital governance best practices.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you very much for this presentation.
[SPEAKER_00]: Very interesting, very important trend of innovation that could have an impact in different aspects, including natural resource management.
[SPEAKER_00]: uh i would like to call on um to come back on the paper please three minutes